okay
and welcome everyone to the webinar how
to build a
successful data analytics career in
retail banking
and finance presented by simply learn
i'm your host stewart freak i'm a
marketing manager here at certain learn
and
my guest today is a thought leader in
data analytics
abhishek a bit more about him in a
moment
first a few notes on how to participate
in this book
your q a button has the question mark on
it
please use q a to ask questions that
we will answer at the end of the webinar
abhishek can i ask you to mute myself
for a moment
[Music]
there we go um
we'll ask the questions of abhishek at
the
end of the webinar in the live q a
session so put your questions
into the q a box through that button
for live chat during the webinar use
the speech bubble button and
if you direct your question to all or
your chat to all panelists
we'll all see it uh if you send it to
host only
um abhishek will not see it so please
use all panelists
we're also going to do a few polls
during the webinar
and the first one has two questions on
it
what's your current job title
and how are you feeling today
on a scale of thumbs up for feeling good
thumbs down if you're not feeling so
well today and
in the middle
and we'll leave the
hole open for about another 45 seconds
and we're getting a lot of responses
coming in
so
you have about 15 more seconds to put in
your responses and hit submit
and let's see the answers
um it's a fairly rounded
group
some managers some students some people
in
operational roles and some
other folks so we hope this will be a
very informative and interesting session
for you i'm going to
introduce
abhishek now
he is the chief analytics officer for
lending cart
with over 19 years of experience in
consulting and
retail financial services he's
co-founder
of infinite and his mba is from the sp
jain institute
and bachelor of engineering from nit
surothko welcome abhishek
thank you stuart good evening everyone
so artistic um
the data is as we've discussed before
very very important very exciting aspect
of uh the digital
and i think what we're hearing now is a
little bit of feedback
um go ahead and tell us about
what it is that you do and how you view
data in this sector
sure so i think uh i'll give a bit of
background in terms of how i've
seen the entire data and analytics piece
grow in india
and in you know countries abroad as well
as how it's impacted banks and
financial services institutions so i
think uh
over the course of my career i've heard
a lot of terms being used for
uh database decisioning so you know you
have heard about analytics data and
analytics
you've heard about uh business
intelligence decision sciences
uh big data analytics and now a machine
learning and
uh yeah right but i think over a period
of time as we have heard these
versions of uh data and analytics uh
evolve
there are three pillars to the entire
database decisioning activity
that have remained steadfast um
the first one has been the actual data
and analytics which is about
uh you know making sure you have quality
data available in a timely manner
and it is accurate uh the other is
obviously
insights that get derived out of it the
second part of it is technology
and technology has played various roles
when i started my career technology was
more about
picking up the analysis that was getting
done and hardwiring it into the systems
to ensure that there was a seamless
integration
of analytics into business the third
part of it which
which is very very critical is really
first-hand business knowledge or domain
knowledge
and uh the three together then create an
entire framework which allows for data
and analytics to be implemented
i think the first two pillars which is
data and analytics and technology
they have been converging or dovetailing
into each other for a very long time
when i started my career about 20 years
back in banks
you know sas was really the default
analytics tool available in the
environment then we had a little bit of
the
technology revolutions level and we had
ibm coming in with spss we had r
which had finally gotten acquired by
microsoft
then we started hearing a lot about you
know big data
and the moment big data analytics came
in
the traditional tools like sas and r
they started integrating seamlessly with
hadoops and clusters and whatnot
um and now we obviously have a much more
integrated and tightly coupled data plus
analytics play which is essentially
around whether you use
python or you know whoever is knocking
on the door next which is julia
right um again about 20 years back we
were creating a lot of pivot tables on
excel sheets uh
and it's only sas was getting used only
for final classification when we wanted
to create
um today when i look at it you know
excel-based analysis is completely
passing
i don't even care about it
[Music]
for banks analytics was only about
using internal performance data of the
borrowers
and combining it with demographic data
that was available in the environment
and creating multiple insights out of it
then came credit bureau
and the entire world of credit
worthiness checks completely changed
today as you look at it you have
multiple sources of data
you have sms data all data records you
have bank statements coming in
you have digital footprint scores like
trusting social coming through
credit bureau has created a complete
niche for itself internal performance
data continues to add value
and i think all of these together have
now created a very very comprehensive
and exhaustive
database decision framework that has
become available
um however and
and you know so therefore you have seen
quite a bit of change on data and
analytics as well as technology
but i think the third pillar which is uh
you know
business knowledge firsthand business
knowledge that continues to be the core
of
everything um so you know you have newer
technology you have newer analytics
techniques like whether it be random
forest whether it be
xgbm or anything else that comes through
finally unless you know they have the
right amount of business knowledge in
the right context for implementation of
analytics
it remains ineffective and therefore i
mean just to summarize
a lot has changed a lot has evolved but
a lot remains the same
you still need to know your numbers you
need to be at your fingertips you need
to have sniff tests coming through
whenever you see any kind of insights or
analysis coming out
uh two the use cases for implementation
of analytics needs to be very very clear
and i think three which is uh you know
last but not least
is that whatever analytics you do
it can't just remain theory it needs to
impact either your p l
or the balance sheet and i think that's
where i see the three pillars
and while they have changed the north
themselves they continue to remain
relevant
back to you students yeah um
um so we talk about the trends
of technology for example
which um
as you said went from specialist tools
like spss
sas
how how has that made the
power of analytics
right so i think um as with
any implementation or any technology
evolution
i think it has its pros and cons right
so
a lot of data became available people
started basing their decisions on a lot
of data
you didn't have to remain a specialist
who only understood modeling
to start using data so you know you you
created multiple dashboards to
understand what's happening in the
portfolio
you started analyzing there were slicing
and dicing tools available
right but what started then happening
was
users began creating their own reports
and therefore from a single source of
truth giving you one particular output
you started having multiple versions of
the same slices and dices
and finally it's about definitional
constructs right
unless your definition of let's say an
approval rate or a delinquency
they remain consistent in the
organization if that doesn't happen then
you start having multiple versions of
the group
and none of them are speaking to each
other so i think
it has had its entire run uh it went
to truly democratic for a very long time
then people started realizing that you
know people were
analyzing to death and therefore people
pulled it a little back
and what started happening was you had a
standard set of frameworks which started
getting implemented over and above that
ad hoc analysis which required a lot of
insights
that started coming back to the decision
sciences team
and that's the construct that you see
today so when uh you know business or
functional units
want to create their own analysis they
use all the standard
outputs that are available they use the
standard data sources
or single source of truth that's
available in the environment
they start using that but when it comes
to any high end analytics or when it
requires deeper insights
they always fall back to the specialist
and therefore the specialists still
continue to occupy
place in the entire system
it's an interesting point
as it happens i'm old enough to remember
when
people said executives will never use
personal computers because it involves
typing
and that's a secretarial job
and of course the power um as i
mentioned the democratization
of having your own um
spreadsheets instead of going to the i.t
department
was too powerful for people to resist
but
as you said giving everybody the tool
doesn't mean you're giving
everybody the skill to interpret
and that that leads to a question
one of the purposes of data
is the main purpose of data as you
described it is to inform
business decisions so that you can
improve p l improve the bottom line
prove the balance sheet and that means
that
specialists have to be able to
communicate to
business generalists um
how do you see that process working in
the in the current
age so i think
um you know in the olden days we used to
talk about business analysts
and we used to talk about techno
functional business analysts who could
understand the technicalities of data
and analytics but at the same time knew
the business lingo new business
terminology
to be able to have a two-way
conversation uh
i think as with any other terminology
now it has become analytics translators
and you have
narrative analytics coming through
wherein it's not just
important to you know create a lot of
information
you have to create one more layer which
is insights
you then on top of it need to create
recommendations
and these recommendations have to be
steeped in analytical constructs
but they have to be simple enough for
business to understand
so i think as with any effective
strategy
the idea always is to make it as
comprehensive and as
complicated or as complex as you want
in the background but the communication
and the narration
has to be simple enough and
implementable enough
for it to have an impact and i think
that
role is still extremely critical as i
said you know
initially that database decisioning is
about the three constructs in terms of
technology data and analytics and
business knowledge
and i think the best uh or the most
effective analytics resources that i
have encountered
have always been people who understand
all three
and therefore are able to portray it in
the right manner understand and evaluate
when a particular analytical construct
needs to be implemented
and then are able to go back talk to the
technical team get it done
and be able to push back and you know
come back to the business users
with the right results
yeah we had a discussion with a
gentleman from salesforce who
field is ai and he was talking about
how the data analytics problem
flows in two directions one is
from what is possible to learn from the
data from the data
specialists saying to the business
people this is what we
can these are insights that we can
derive from the data available
but it also flows in the other direction
which is the business people saying
these are the insights that we need to
have
what can you tell us from the data
that's available
so um i think that's an
interesting area do you have some
insights into that
so yeah i think a lot of places where i
think it's a dream
um so for example um you know
i i was doing some bit of collection
strategy
uh last week right and
the whole idea was uh given you know
india was
going through the entire moratorium
period we are coming off moratorium on
first of september or yesterday
and um you know you need to capacitize
your collections workforce to the right
uh
amount and geographically right
for it to be effective and therefore it
needs a whole lot of predictions with
respect to how many bounces you are
going to see on the portfolio
uh which buckets with geography uh you
know whether it's a hard collection soft
collection there is a whole lot of
analytics that you need to create to get
to the answer right
and you know my collections had actually
came to me and said abhishek you know
i think this is my understanding of
uh you know business i think this is the
total number of bounces that will happen
and this i think is the overall
construct uh wherein you know there'll
be
some bit of kelly calling some bit of
geographical spreads on the
on the field collectors do you have data
available
with you which allows me to triangulate
and validate my assumptions
right so it's a classic business problem
there is a lot of gut feel involved
people have some sort of an
understanding basis their understanding
of business
as to what needs to be done but they
need validation from data right
um what we did was uh you know we
typically
have asked for a lot of bank statements
from our customers
and lending card typically does a lot of
bank statement based underwriting
and a lot of and therefore that became
the de facto model for me
to then go back to these bank statements
get the latest ones
and then try to understand you know uh
how has the service ability
or the ability to service a loan gone
down in the times of the pandemic for
the customer right
and then we kind of recirculated it and
we figured out therefore if the
serviceability is going down
what is the expected bounce rate on my
portfolio
then we cut it by various buckets we
looked at net flow rates
and you know funnily enough we realized
that the collection set was very very
close to the actual number that we got
so you know while we while we do a lot
of data and analytics i think
the field of business still remains very
relevant and it's always a two-way flow
there are a lot of analytics outputs
that we create on our own
but then again it also flows the other
way around
um
let me mute you for a second so we have
the
echo off
uh there are a couple questions actually
coming in through the chat
and i think i'd like to uh
if i may
take a look at a couple of those
uh one one i think we'll come into
the subject a little bit more detail
later but
one person asks what are the basic needs
for somebody
who wants to enter the industry as a
data scientist
i think uh i think two parts to the
answer honestly um one obviously you
need to
you need to have a problem-solving
approach to things
so as you look at a problem that is
coming to you
uh you need to be able to structure the
output very clearly
you need to first be able to you know
cut the problem into multiple parts
create a structure around it be able to
answer that with
the help of data and analytics obviously
that would require a lot of technical
skill sets
some of it could be pure you know just
being able to pull data from a
particular database
then put it into a python or whatever
create a script
create the right sort of you know data
summarizations on it and then be able to
present it i think that's the first
skill set
the second skill set is uh you need to
understand the context
in which you are solving the problem
right so there is one part of it was
just pure technique
i think the second part which is equally
relevant is as i said a domain knowledge
right
so if i'm solving for let's say a credit
cards business
i need to understand what are the
drivers of the credit card business
i need to understand the terms and
terminologies so
you know i shouldn't be scratching my
head if
i see a credit card problem and it's
talking about a you know hard revolver
or a soft revolver
or it's talking about delinquencies or
it's talking about never use never pay
or spends or
any such thing right so i think you need
to have
both of them very very focused so what i
would suggest if you're starting your
data and analytics career is
be very very sharp on the technical
skill sets that you want to develop
make sure that you have a structured
thought process
but also more relevant when you are
approaching a particular industry
for beginning your career be aware
of some of the parts of the industry
right it is very very helpful
i mean one of the one of the crips that
we always have with our education system
today
is that you know they teach us a whole
lot but what they don't teach us is
for retail banking what are the 20
critical things i need to know
if i need to go into retail what are the
20 things that i need to know
and i think the moment we start having
that business focused uh you know
evaluation metrics available on the
academic side or
in terms of you know even simply learn
packages right uh the moment you have
very specific concise packages
on what needs to be known for a
particular industry
i think that becomes very old
that's interesting because that echoes a
piece of advice that was in a book i
read
many years ago about job interviewing
and it cited the example of somebody
going to a
sugar manufacturer and there were two
candidates
and the one candidate had a lot of
technical knowledge about
the function that they were going to do
in this
particular department the other
candidate however
knew that you made sugar in this
particular case by harvesting sugarcane
breaking it down extracting the cane
juice
distilling you know or refining that
and so he had a great deal of
information about or knowledge about the
industry even though maybe less
technical knowledge about that
particular
job function and of course
that industry knowledge is what helps
you get hired because
you can always refine your technical
skills or
upskill yourself but to start in an
industry with the the basic knowledge of
the industry
gives you a leg up because you don't
have to be
subject to as much intensive training on
just the basics of the industry
so what i'd like to ask is you had
mentioned
your recent challenges
in using analytics to see what the
impact of the pandemic has been
on your business what do you think the
impact of the pandemic has been
on consumer behavior and
second question what has the impact been
on how you conduct
data analytics within lending
sure so stuart um
i mean in these times
when it is a pretty tragic time with a
lot of uh
businesses a lot of people's
fundamentally their
financial stress has changed and the way
they were
financially stable yesterday has
completely taken a beating
um i actually uh land in a
in a particular environment where uh
landing card typically does loans only
for micro and small smes
so therefore we are actually lending to
the most stressed segment in the current
scenario
because while you and i typically get
our paychecks still
you know these are people who are not
able to open their shops during the
panama
and therefore you know their businesses
are fundamentally changed
so what's happened is you know you are
facing a very typical scenario
where your prior performance even on my
book
is not guaranteeing that you will
continue to perform well
secondly in terms of credit worthiness
checks
uh or underwriting uh you know checks
um my credit models are not just
you know changing on the calibration but
they are also changing on rank ordering
itself so you know if i had done a
relative rank ordering of customers
basis their risk
and i had created abcdef today it is
not necessary that an a-rank customer
will continue to perform better than a
b-rank customer right
and that creates a completely new
problem right because
as you are coming out of pandemic you
will obviously focus a lot on
collections but your business also needs
to start growing
for business to start growing your
models have to start working again
because otherwise you go back to manual
underwriting which is not necessarily
the right thing to do
now at lending card we have been
slightly fortunate
because uh what we have always done is
we have looked at
customers application data euroscope and
we have also looked at bank statements
and typically you know a 12-month bank
statement we are able to use to predict
what is the ability of a customer to pay
now that bank statement today even today
reflects the right picture
primarily because you know we had
demonetization in 2016
and because of that a lot of the
transactions have gone digital and
therefore are available on the bank
statements
and even the payments etc have gone
digital so my entire net debits credits
uh you know average daily balances
everything is reflecting the right
picture
so we are still able to you know
understand which customers are
undergoing a severe stress which are not
but i think it again provides a
wonderful opportunity also
because you can fundamentally relook at
your models
you can get in newer sources of data
like bank statements to start evaluating
more
and you can get if not bank statements
any other
imputation of income which allows you to
very
clearly you know find out the financial
stability of a business
or a person and use that to create your
models
but i mean honestly the world has
changed completely
and credit worthiness itself has
completely taken a
uh made a change
and what about the uh behavior of
consumers and businesses on
on on the other side of the table from
you
um what have you observed changing over
this
this period so i think uh
when you lend to a borrower you
typically always used to look at
uh two tenants one was the ability to
pay
the second was intent to pay i think the
intent to pay still remains strong
it's the ability which has changed uh i
think to the
entire mix given that india had
undergone a six month monitoring period
um there is a third tenant which is now
getting introduced
which is the habit to pay so you know
getting the customers to make them
remember there is an emi that is you
and therefore they need to get back into
the habit of that payment
that is going to be one of the most
fundamental challenges
and uh what will also happen is uh this
habit to pay will start reflecting in
the way people
uh underwrite right so for example a
customer who had taken a moratorium
usually a customer who had not taken a
monitoring
they will be viewed separately so i
think you'll now suddenly have three
tenets of underwriting
ability to pay intent to pay and have it
to pay i think we have been very
fortunate we have been very
closely communicating with our customers
even the customers who have been unable
to pay
and have taken a moratorium during this
period i think the
intent which is really the driving force
of any collections capability that
remains very strong
so collectors so you know our customers
have continuously told us that
yes we are undergoing a stress but do
not worry the moment my business opens
up
yours will be one of the first loans
i'll pay so don't worry about it
i think that really puts us in a good
frame of mind
as we as we get into september
um this would be a good point to do
another
quick poll and this one
has to do with what data science skills
people currently have
so here's a sampling of a few different
categories
and if you take a moment just
let us know what skills you currently
use in your
work
and of course you can select more than
one
and again we will leave this poll open
not for five minutes but for just
about another one minute from now
and
as i'm looking in the one clear trend
that's showing up
is that big data is not part of the
most people's equation right now but um
we'll leave that open for about another
15 seconds you have a chance to make
your selections and hit
submit
all right and you can see
that people who answered data analytics
is the primary skill that they use
um business analytics ai and machine
learning are also
important and we'll come back to a
variation on this question later
so
i'm curious to know um
with the advances in
analytics and technology with
what people have learned about through
various
iterations of using the analytics
for business decisions and then driving
that to ask
better questions what new areas
have opened up or what new applications
do you see becoming possible because of
the power of data analytics
so i think uh let me let me take a
stab at it from a banking and financial
services perspective
given that you know that's closer to my
heart um
i think in terms of uh
in terms of new areas i think what will
what will typically start happening is
there has always been a lot of analytics
around
the initial customer acquisition right
so
uh what kind of seo optimizations to do
to get the customer on your book
or on your website how do you you know
work on the funnel further
to make sure that the conversion into a
terms and conditions or a dispersal is
higher etc
i think one of the pieces which has been
lagging behind
in the financial services industry
specifically has been collections
analytics
and i think historically people always
knew that you are never in the business
of lending
you are in the business of collecting
because today if i stand with 100 rupees
on the road and i say who wants it
and if i'm not asking back the money
then
anybody and everybody will pick it up
right but the moment they know that they
have to pay it back
that's the trick right understanding
which person i need to give this hundred
rupees to
so that i'll get it back so i think what
has fundamentally happened is
given the entire financial stress that
has happened in the system
elections has become of utmost
importance and
collections always used to be a lot of
manual effort you know
collectors were on spreadsheets they
used to call the customers on their
mobile phones
never have uh you know feedback loops
for coming in
there were no analytics there were no or
there were limited amount of you know
uh collections analytics saying which
customer will flow forward which
customer will flow backward and so on
and so forth
so i think that particular area is going
to be completely
full of analytics and analysis and
analysis right now
and i think it will continue to be the
case the second part
that i see analytics coming through big
time is
there is a whole lot of data on the
phone today
now what's happened is uh you know we we
do store a lot of applications on our
phone
and we give access to these application
access to
every single data point on my phone to
these applications but what
does not happen is uh if there is a
lender's application so for example you
know if
if there is a lending card application
even the people who take a loan from
lending card about five to ten percent
will really download that application
and therefore
the ability of a lender to use data
that's lying on the phone which is very
rich
is very limited i think the second part
of analytics which is going to
be really really important will be how
do i
drive adoption of my application onto
the phone
and therefore be able to get the right
and regulated information
out of it so i think that's the other
part there are many sdks there are many
codes which are available but i think
where it's falling short right now is
people are not downloading your app
enough
to be able to get uh meat out of it so i
think that's the other part where
analytics on on financial services will
increase
the third part is uh in the adoption of
mln
so what's happened over a period of time
is uh
there are two very divergent views
on using mlna
the moment you're talking about revenue
generating activities
people are happy using unsupervised
algorithms which have learnt over a
period of time
and even if there is a drop it's only a
drop in the revenue
and that you can keep correcting but the
moment you talk about
unsupervised learning or an algorithm
available on the
on the underwriting part of it the risk
managers take a step backward
and they say no but you know here we
need to control it we need to ensure
that not too many people are
going bad etc etc so i think the
adoption
of ml codes and unsupervised learning
on the underwriting side has been very
low and that's the other part which will
go up but the last part will be the
entire aips right the entire chat bots
or voice bots
uh you know metlife for example in
europe
has has taken over a bond which
effectively
can talk to you like a normal human
being
and what it does is it takes away your
entire service delivery platform from a
human and a human capital intensive uh
you know output mechanism
to a replication of technology and the
moment you know
sentiment analysis understanding of the
tone with behaviors etc becomes better
that becomes my scalable option right so
i think that's the other part where we
will see on customer service
then we will see a lot of adoption
a little mouse problem there for a
second
um yeah that's a fascinating aspect
both in terms of
evolving trust for ml and ai
where people have to be convinced that
the machine
can do it as well as a person and
they'll probably end up finding out that
the machine can do it
better in a lot of cases but the other
aspect is
you know the the impact of ai
in scalability of service where
you don't have to fill as many seats in
a call
center if the ai can
handle much of that work and
as you said with sentiment analysis if
the ai
is smart enough to know when the
customer is very angry
and you know how to how to treat that
i had a question in the
chat which had to do with the timing of
data and the timing of analysis
and can you comment on
whether you know different fields
require real-time data collection
and you know whether that's a
cost-effective thing for them to do
so i think um
one thing that we all need to remember
is you don't have equal data
so the cost of data keeps increasing as
you get
nearer to real time right so
uh what you need to create as a data
strategy when you are talking about
refresh frequencies etc
is to clearly identify which part of
your data do you need real time
so for example for banks one of the
critical pieces that they need to know
is
are there atms functioning are the atms
running out of cash
right now that is absolute real-time
requirement
on the other hand the bank does not
really need to know how many total
you know savings accounts have been
booked absolutely real time
because it's not a competition right you
can have it you can have a two hour
delay you can have a four hour delay
some of them
with the p minus one so i think it is
very important to know that
the cost of data increases exponentially
as you get to real time
and therefore identification of the
right data strategy
to know which data is critical which is
non-critical what can take
p minus 1 t minus 2 etc is very critical
and that's how most of the banks today
are typically performed
we have a question about
whether it's better to start
from the perspective of
studying ai and ml
as a way into
modern practice of data science or
whether you start from the data science
and analytics
side and i
suspect i know what your answer might be
but i'd like you to comment
um it's an interesting one because
i think one is more a technology while
the other is more
an understanding of the context view and
to my mind it has to be a combination i
don't think we are walking away anytime
soon from the fact
that you do need to know your data you
do need to understand the basic
practices
you need to know how to evaluate data
quality missing value
fillers and whatnot to be able to create
the right and relevant outputs
at the same time i think this is a very
exciting time because technology is
literally changing every month
right every new month that you wake up
you suddenly realize there's a julia
who's knocking on the door it's python
you know two weeks back
so on and so forth so i think it is
important for you to take one technology
really understand it well because what
happens is that the implementation of
that technology is what will matter
and for that you will need to know that
technology and the
language well and you will need to
understand the context
without both of them being in place you
will always struggle
so i think it's a combination that you
need to create and uh
you know if you're a fresher who's
getting into a new interview
it is okay to be heavily oriented
towards mln ai
or heavily oriented towards just a
python script or just a sas script
but have a working knowledge of the
context to which you're walking
and i think both of them together then
become a really
irresistible you know output for
somebody to
take into the organization
and related to that because we're
talking about
kind of developing the t-shaped set of
knowledge with
in-depth understanding of a particular
technology as a specialist
but a generalist understanding of the
entire field so that you know how to
communicate and work in that with other
people who are
other specialists but what are some of
the other
non-technical skills that you see
as important in an analytics career
something on the non-technical side of
it uh
one the art of storytelling is very
critical
uh it's not just about uh you know great
insights
it's also about being able to explain
those insights well to your audience
and uh you know there are various ways
of storytelling right there is deductive
very inductive
so you need to know the audience to
which you are addressing
and then accordingly decide how you want
to run the story
right uh whether you want to you know do
a slow unravel
or you give the output first and the
recommendations first
and then you go into how you have come
across it right
so i think narrative storytelling is one
large
uh you know non-technical skill set that
is required
i think the other skill set that is
required and uh
a lot of people actually don't pay too
much attention to it
is a relationship building and i'll tell
you why
i might be the best data scientist in
the
entire universe but if my
functional stakeholders do not trust me
enough i haven't built the right
relationships
whatever i give as an output if it is
not adopted
it will not be impactful and a lot of
the adoption that you see
of your analytical outputs are based on
how much
trust do you have in the entire
environment that you function
um so i think those two are
extremely key skill sets narrative
storytelling
and relationship building which are very
critical to a successful career
and i think that's going to take us to
our last poll before the live q a
so if i may so i said it's it's similar
to the last one but
this one we're asking what are the
skills
that you want to learn we asked you
before what you currently use
what would you like to add to your
repertoire or your toolbox
and i'll leave this open for about a
minute or so
and this gets back to your point avishek
about
the need to be
broad and more generalist
in your approach to complement your
specialist
knowledge of a particular technology or
area so
let me
go ahead it'll be about another 15
seconds that the polls open so please
get your answers in
remember to hit submit
and
in this case ai and machine learning the
most popular answer but still followed
by data analytics
that makes sense
bear with me for a moment
i will get to the live questions that
we've been accumulating
and because of our
audio issues i'm going to have to
mute you in between the questions while
i'm asking a question
but then i'll unmute you
so a specific question for the industry
how does data science
impact audit firms and
how can audit firms approve their
improve their audit
quality using data
[Music]
okay that's slightly different one um i
think
look audit is finally about um
it can be multiple kinds of audits so
let me take a first a generate
you know a general stab at it and let me
see if i'm answering the question
uh you could have forensic analytics in
audit you could be looking at you know
multiple uh
frauds that are happening you could look
at transactions you could look at
how pnls are constructed you could look
at uh teams and dreams of data about you
know whether your
accounts are reconciling with your uh
with your loan management systems or
your
poor banking systems etc so i think it
is all about
reconciling data making sure that
multiple sources of data are talking to
each other and giving out the same
output
so i think any audit essentially at the
end of the day
will always look at reconciliation and
therefore data analytics obviously plays
a very large part there
some of it may use the right tools in
terms of you know models or in terms of
standard frameworks
some of it could be ad hoc but you know
the structured problem-solving approach
of reconciliation
will always revolve around data audience
a question here a couple of questions
that are related about
data quality okay
so how do you ensure data quality
and how do you make sure that data is
unbiased
okay so i think uh two parts the
question one is with respect to
insurance of
data quality so what i've always uh
you know what i've always stressed on is
before you use any sort of data your
data store needs to give out a relevant
report
which which looks at checks and balances
which looks at missing values which
looks at
any values in the warehouse which are
which are violating the norms that you
have set for that particular field
and you need to make sure that you
create a data score
a data quality score which could be you
know weighted
on your mandatory parameters with a
good to have parameters also involved in
it
and what you then need to do is after
you look at the data quality report
you need to get the uh exceptions out
they need to go back to a data owner
who then needs to work on that
particular data set which is wrong or
data record which is wrong
it needs to come back into the warehouse
a new trailing data quality needs to get
created
and then you need to compare whether
that data quality is improving over a
period of time
so uh i think having the right date i
mean
we have all heard right it's finally
garbage in garbage out or
your analytics insights are limited by
the
quality of data that you build those
insights on etc
so i think uh having a very standard
and a thorough framework on data quality
is unquestionably the bedrock on which
any analytics
team will work on and there are multiple
ways of
ensuring that you know by making it
unbiased is one way
missing value fillers or another way uh
you know taking out the tails in terms
of all the extremes whether maybe on the
lower side of the higher side
that's another way of doing it there are
multiple techniques available
sorry stuart can't hear you i i muted
you for
just the last second of what you were
saying
um so we have questions here now
from people who are in the field that
studied commerce are in the field of
business or finance and
one of the questions is whether someone
should have a degree in finance to
to become a data scientist in a
finance-based organization and the other
is
if you have an accounting or commercial
background
how do you move into analytics for
finance
so i think whether you need to have
uh you know an analytics degree or a
quant degree
um it gives you an advantage
definitely because i think uh
it it it just teaches you a little bit
of structure right so whether it be uh
whether it be a you know an engineering
degree whether it be a commerce degree i
think
if you're familiar with numbers if
you're familiar with some of the
econometric concepts
it obviously gives you a leg up that
said
some of the best you know analysts that
i have seen
have come in from pure economic
backgrounds iiscs and so on
right who are the best modelers in town
and they
and some of them really pick up well on
the business concepts also
so i think an mba degree uh helps
more from a rounding up perspective that
it allows you to understand business a
little more
and therefore you know translate
whatever is coming out of the analytics
into the right business context the
degrees finally are just
an additional leg up uh that help you
get better at what you are doing that
said
some of the leaders in data science
today
they haven't even finished colleges
right so i think finally
it's about whether you have the right
structured approach to problem solving
and if you have that
i don't think anything else is really
needed to
kind of you know push you up but each of
these
uh degrees for each of these
certifications give you certain skill
sets or add certain skill sets to your
repertoire
which help you succeed well
on the commerce side of it i think look
there is an entire piece on fpma and cfo
and you know financial accounting and
financial analytics
which is a wide open area and that is
that demand
that skill set is hugely in demand fpma
typically
is one of the most exciting you know
data analytics based roles that are
available in any organization
under the cfo you typically always have
one or two
uh you know analysts who look at balance
sheets and pnls
who look at you know what kind of xiras
or iras the business is generating
looks at roa roe and whatnot right
so i think given that you if you have a
commerce background you understand these
terms
i think pick up some part of the fpna
pick up some part of the entire cfo
analytics pieces
and that could become a very easy you
know climb up for you
for getting a good career into
data and analytics on the financial side
of it
excellent um an interesting question
and it has to do with running through an
example of how your data analytics
data analytics team decide
which statistical modeling
to use on a specific scenario can you
maybe run through a quick example of how
you do that
[Music]
sure so um i mean
i'll give you a different kind of an
example
uh we typically had a lot of customers
who came to me for a loan but finally
did not
end up taking that loan right so if i
have
uh if i have given out you know a
million loans
i would typically have about 50 million
uh
you know prospects would have approached
me at some point in time
and for different reasons i may have
even underwritten them but they have not
picked up their loans
right uh now as you create a
re-engagement campaign
you now are starting with a funnel which
is very large
and therefore your normal practices of
running a random forest or even a
xgbm might not remain as relevant
so what you would end up doing is uh
using a
google tester at creating some feature
mapping to ensure that you understand
what were the contours of that
population so given that the data is
large
you accordingly change the way you are
analyzing it
to reach to a conclusion and for example
when we when we utilize all this feature
mapping in this particular case
we realize that uh literally five
percent of this population is all that i
need to target
to get to about eighty percent response
out of this
and i think therefore it is very
relevant for you to
look at designing your structure of the
analysis right
so you know create your problem
statements that this is the problem i
need to solve
then look at which is the right and
relevant technique to implement on that
particular piece of work
uh you know have your design
conversations and only
once you're convinced that this is the
right way of moving forward you then
start actually analyzing and you know
closing out the problem
what sorry you were a newt i couldn't
hear you i'm sorry
um at this point i'd like to ask if you
have final thoughts that you'd want to
share with the audience to sum up
so um i'll turn it over to you
sure i think
this is a sunrise industry and i think
uh
it will remain very relevant for a very
long time to come
over a period of time what will end up
happening is uh
and it's already starting to happen that
data and analysis
has become a de facto skill set that
people expect
from any business leader so you know go
on are the days when your sales guy
had no idea of numbers or how they
arrived at it right
uh now there is sales forecasting people
understand that you know if i am on
next day of a month how do i predict
where to get by the month and
so on so i think data and analysis uh
will become the de facto skill set uh
there will obviously be a lot more
adoption
of ai and ml the amount of use cases in
the relevant
use cases for some of these newer
technologies
will continue to grow i think
what will also end up happening is all
the
all the historical ways of treating data
looking at data
as technology keeps evolving and newer
techniques of analysis keep on coming in
the adoptions will increase manifold and
you will start seeing
a lot more dependence on automated
decision
rather than human decision uh so that's
where i see it going
and it will not just happen on the
marketing side of it on the customer
service delivery side of it
i think over a period of time and it's
already starting to happen
you'll start having a lot of automated
decisions on the
acquisition for the uh you know getting
the customer on the book side of it
um over and above that obviously you can
see a lot of ai and ml coming
on you know chat bots you go to any
website there are bots talking to you
uh you go to any shop floor you have a
whole lot of robots working on it
and therefore you'll see a lot of ai and
ml coming through into
mercedes-benz for example so you know
automated temperature controls there is
iot
happening you know tomorrow i'll be able
to switch on my ac before half an hour
before i get home and then i
you know very soon i won't have to do it
every day
i just have to set an alarm and you know
automatically my pcs will come on right
so i think it is it is going to become
an integral part of our lives
and therefore the use cases will not
just remain in the professional
environment
but also in the personal lives and
i think it's for the best but at the
same time i think
after all of that is said and done uh
nothing works better than a
smile in the morning and saying hi
i think we shouldn't ever forget that
but
i'm really looking forward to the right
adoption of ai animal
in all aspects of life
wonderful um this has been a really
excellent experience and and really
thank you for
for your time and i'm going to ask if
if you'd like to share
how people can reach you
and
me
hold on a second
uh
yeah go ahead and tell people how they
can get in touch with you or
think with you on social media sure i
think uh
i'm available as abhishek singh on
linkedin india
so i think uh you know please uh proper
note uh connect with me
happy to answer any questions privately
uh you know
you want to you want to talk to me you
know just help me up on linkedin itself
i'm usually quite active on linkedin
so i think that would be the right
platform
excellent and we want to thank you again
for um joining us and
i want to thank everybody here for being
part of the
webinar we have another webinar coming
up
one week from tonight wednesday
september 9th
a career management master class how
building a career is like building a
successful startup
our guest will be tianhari who is the
head of hr at big basket
and we hope you will all join us for
that
we also have our methods for
staying in touch with simply learn on
the different social platforms facebook
twitter and linkedin and we invite you
to join with us
and thank you all this is the end of the
webinar
um so i'd like to invite everyone to log
off and when you do
you should see a survey if you would
answer that survey
that will help us improve future
webinars
again thanks everybody and goodbye
[Music]
you